desperate for answers about her son who
has been missing for more than three
decades
they took him from home around 10 pm
saying they needed to get some
information until today there has been
no news of him it's been 33 years it
happened on the 7th of November 1989
around 10 pm my son was sleeping he was
just 17 years old
now local and international rights
groups have released a report called
Mars Graves failed exhumations which
looks at how justice has been denied to
thousands of victims of Sri Lanka's
violent past
we have the most important factor
negatively impacting examination so far
is the political interference our legal
and policy framework is inadequate we
have also seen the exhibition sites are
not always well protected rights groups
have been helping families the victims
of forced disappearances when skeletons
were found during construction work here
at the marthalaya government hospital
aryavathi and hundreds like her thought
they may finally find answers
155 skeletons were recovered some with
bullet wounds and other injuries
I have informed that the course
regarding that there are there are
features of a scene of crime in this
site local experts estimated The Remains
were from the country's second Marxist
Insurgency in the late 80s but the case
was closed after carbon dating said they
were from much earlier
more than 350 skeletons were Unearthed
at this Mass grave site in Mana in the
northwest of the country activists
believe it contains the remains of
people killed during the war between the
military and Tamil tiger separatists
the delay in identifying The Remains has
been extremely frustrating for families
it's Justice that we are asking for we
don't want compensation how can you
compensate for the loss of our loved
ones the Sri Lankan government did not
respond to Al jazeera's request for a
comment on the report but in an
interview on French television President
Ryan vikrama Singh has said any
allegation regarding Mass Graves can be
taken to the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission which is about to be set up
critics say the contents of the report
are a sad indictment of a state that
should be ensuring Justice for its
citizens
but according to authors there's no
political will to do that a fact that
will bring no Comfort to families
waiting for answers
Al Jazeera Colombo